she's like somebody stole the car like
woke up my dad woke up my brothers like
we gotta call the police like somebody
sold the car didn't even think that it
was it was me and my brother goes hold
on before you do that let me just check
Lane's room real quick go to my room I'm
not there he goes calls me he's like
someone's still Colleen too
[Laughter]
[Music]
so in Nebraska there was a high-speed
car chase I'm talking like went all the
way through central Nebraska topping 100
miles per hour in the passenger seat of
this poor car that was going in the
speed chase was 11 year old boy the
driver
his 13 year old older sister wow
I thought it was the 11 year old how did
she learn how to drive dude 100 miles an
hour imagine a [__] 13 year old kid
just you're freaking the [__] out all
this [__] Reckless huh dude I mean this
is Colorado too I don't know if like
he's just in Nebraska the [__] the
driver was a girl from Colorado sorry I
was eventually taken at a protective
custody so yeah this 13 year old girl
LED state troopers on a high-speed car
chase through central Nebraska on Monday
but the driver was a girl from Colorado
who was eventually taken into productive
custody along with the vehicle's only
pastor and 11 year old boy according to
Nebraska state patrol so they bit so
they did the whole road trip from
Colorado I don't know I guess so
Troopers responded to the incident with
help from the Buffalo County Sheriff's
Office in Shelton Police Department the
agency said uh both children were
successfully stopped while traveling
down an interstate highway damn and they
were in a Nissan Pathfinders dude to Not
Crash
you know impressive maybe the the roads
in Nebraska are [__] empty it's empty
and it's just one straight road I could
see that yeah easy to go 120 on a street
road empty yeah the Nissan Pathfinder is
a [__] beautiful view they performed
a tactical maneuver that forced the
Pathfinder to stop and proceeded to take
both the young girl and boy into
protective custody without further
incident so that was good I did throw
those spiky strips
that sounds like it would lead to a
[__] incident you're gonna crash with
them yeah I have no idea though maybe I
I really don't know they probably like
trapped them or something like that they
were like do you want candy okay
Troopers then found a firearm a small
amount of marijuana and drug
paraphernalia inside they're sorry
gangsters dude 13 and 11.
all right that's that's some games was
11 year old boy smoking weed like faster
or maybe they didn't know that was in
the car oh yeah maybe oh like it's their
parents well I would like to hope it's
possible it doesn't say anything like if
your kids are out doing that you
probably are bad parents yeah chances
are oh Nissan Pathfinder though I was
thinking it would be more like a classic
you know like a Starsky and Hutch kind
of situation with a big rebel flag on
their hood and then like I don't know
just like a Mazda
Mazda Miata hey they're badass dude like
a Mini Cooper they're [__] super
badass but this uh this kind of makes me
think obviously that's basically all
that happened good job state troopers
um what was something that y'all did as
kids that was just like kind of you know
kind of the farthest thing that you did
as a kid in terms of illegal or
something that may have gotten you in
trouble I sold the car 18 stories wait
sold no stole oh you stole a car no I
stole my parents car oh
pretty much what they did yeah pretty
much with that but I would just go to
parties as so basically uh I think it
was like 15. this is like after the rock
cleaning stuff yeah I was like I'm gonna
get them back
um
I caught my brother sneaking back into
the house and I caught him stealing the
car so you got the idea and so I said oh
if you're gonna do this I get to do this
how old was your brother he's a year
older so
um and then I was like okay well then I
get to do this he goes okay fine one
time just don't get uh caught it's like
no problem neither of you had licenses
at the time uh we had permits oh okay
let's do it you just got yours at 15. oh
so you know how to drive a little bit
too yeah it's on a foreign machine no
not completely but also a little bit
terrifying yeah yeah yeah
um like I remember driving be like oh my
headlights aren't on probably should
turn those on all right trying to figure
out what's suspicious yeah
um so I caught him doing it I was like
okay well I get to do this too and I
remember sneaking down and I I did it a
few times never got caught
um probably like a good
five to six times on the seventh time
crazy the only reason why I got caught
was because my neighbors were making a
lot of noise at like two three in the
morning I woke my mom up she went
downstairs went outside
um
you know confronted my neighbors walked
back in I was like wait something was
missing
in the garage like it's not there or
and uh she's like somebody stole the car
like woke up my dad woke up my brothers
like we gotta call the police like
somebody stole the car didn't even think
that it was it was me and my brother
goes hold on before you do that let me
just check lean's room real quick
goes to my room I'm not there and he
goes calls me he's like someone stole
Colleen too
[Laughter]
holy [__] the good brother I wish I wish
um no but he did give me a heads up
though he did call me first because bro
um well yeah Lance called me first and
was like Hey like he got caught just
like going
don't come back never return go to
Nebraska
it's your only way out I'm gonna die no
headlights on that drive like
um oh God you got caught like wrap it up
um I told him not to call the cops like
get home and uh then like moments later
I get a call from my mom I don't pick it
up I'm like
what am I gonna say and then so like I
was like you know what [__] it I'm
already out I might as well enjoy the
last moments of my freedom
I might because I'm gonna get grounded
for life like I know my parents are so
strict
um so I was like I might as well enjoy
like the hard to argue with that logic
though two hours of my freedom but the
problem was that I I felt so much
anxiety that I was already caught that I
couldn't even enjoy the party so I ended
up just driving back anyways it was in
your head like yeah oh yeah shaking a
little way home right just driving back
anyways were you were you drinking
um yeah I had drinks yeah but not not as
bad as it was like when I got caught in
Santa Barbara and had my friend oh yeah
that's not as bad at all
yeah not that bad I had a um
convert like a like a little kind of get
together and on Instagram with one of my
friends
that I had my one of my first major
run-ins with the law we got caught
painting uh Elementary School like
graffiti and some painting
[Laughter]
with graffiti
press that picture Joe at the Beret yeah
and then the Beretta Bob Ross
and the funny thing is like we were so
full broad daylight dude we just
finished the train yard we hopped the
fence and we're just like oh we got away
from the patrol like security that
patrols the train yard we hopped the
fence and we're just like oh here's a
wall and we just went some kids were
playing basketball and we were thinking
like oh they think we're so cool they
were [__] rats they just went and
like ratted on us cops just waited for
us we didn't run or nothing whoa in that
day like
that was the last day I saw a lot of the
the guys in my crew completely gone and
then this guy he he DMS me on Instagram
and he goes dude how's it been I saw you
on tigerbelly talking about graffiti all
this and that he goes I'm still doing it
man like and he's like 40. oh [__] it
just popped out like like second kid or
something like that and he goes he did
his lady did I don't know if she's a
wife or whatever he did he pushed that
out himself yeah
well like life is like it's like a young
man's thing but he's still painting like
from that incident on like what he must
be that was like when I was 13. that was
like 13 or 14. that's tight that's so
like
fast forward to now we we're chatting
I'm in Hawaii I'm just like [__]
giggling in bed chills who are you
talking to oh this guy you know one of
my painter friends
so many memories right after school art
classes
I'm like giggling in bed and goes oh I
gotta go to Hawaii one day well how's it
like he showed me all his art and [__]
and then I'm like so you still hit the
chains and you still do all this stuff
and he goes yeah man like after that
time when we all got caught see I was
like yo this is stupid like I didn't
even go to jail for crime like real
crime like I got caught for painting
like I didn't even make money doing this
I keep calling that so yeah why do you
keep following my mind goes to a
different visual every time you have an
ease a little bit we call it painting
it's like we don't call it like we we're
going graffiti guys I think they call it
vandalism yeah be making it sound like
Michelangelo
I guess it's inside baseball right
that's what they that's what painters
like like I just have like the whole
SWAT team just breaks into like a
painting class
like a little holding wine glasses with
middle-aged women or like the dudes that
like that graffiti up like rocks on like
a hiking trail like oh God hate those
guys they'll go to like Sedona and just
like tag the Rocks like what are you
guys doing man that's the worst dude but
that was my first experience going to
the police station because I did
something wrong dealing with the court
system dealing with having a probation
officer all that I never like back then
like we did have online we had AOL but
like people just went missing like you
just never talk to people ever again
that's true yeah and then years later
like I get DM like oh [__] like what's
up and that was just mind-blowing to me
that his life he just kept going and
became a really good you know painter
yeah and um I just completely quit it
but then he was like yeah I remember too
you were telling me you're getting into
deeper gang [__] at one point and I'm
all like I forgot these conversations
like completely but he remembered it and
then yeah but I don't know that would be
my first experience 13-ish and I still
had the record and I remember I had to
go to the county because when I we
wanted to become cops I I had to show an
effort to expunge it so you can if when
you're a miner you can expunge cases
it's still visible to law enforcement
anybody that wants to do a background
check but then like when you become over
18 and they're doing a background check
on like what you've done or whatever
everything that's done as a miner you
can't see it like for regular employers
yeah if you're trying to work out like
Starbucks or something you know
yeah can't believe you got in trouble
for painting yeah all right it's hot I
like if the cop if you you're telling
you want to be a cop and then they're
like well you got some stuff on your
record but maybe you can just paint over
it